Це мітинг прихильників військового перевороту в Нігері.
На зібранні палять французькі триколори, натомість - піднімають російські
і скандують "Хай живе Путін!"
У нас є уран, діаманти, золото, нафта, а ми живемо, як раби! Чому?
Ми не можемо з цим змиритися. Французький контингент має піти з Нігеру.
Нам не потрібні французи.
Генералу треба бути дуже обачним,
бо народ Нігера розраховує на нього.
Якщо він піде на якісь маневри з Заходом - ми знову вийдемо сюди.
Нігер - колишня французька колонія - нині контролюється
військовою хунтою на чолі з армійським генералом Абдурахманом Тчіані.
Демократично обраного президента Мохамеда Базума
силою відсторонили від влади. Його вважали союзником Заходу.
Також він підтримував цілісність України в ООН.
Сусідні Малі й Буркіна-Фасо, де раніше владу теж захопили військові,
підтримали переворот. США, ЄС, Україна - засудили.
Росія - стурбована, але, як кажуть експерти, ще й зацікавлена.
Вірогідний інтерес до Нігера з боку Росії.
Нещодавно відбувся саміт, на якому пообіцяли допомогу країнам
африканського регіону із зерном.
Крім того привертає увагу заява очільника ПВК "Вагнер"
Пригожина з приводу перевороту в Нігері,
де проводиться паралель між сучасною Росією і Радянським Союзом,
який допомагав боротися з колоніалістами.
Попри російські прапори на мітингах, аналітики не вважають,
що Москва безпосередньо причетна до повалення демократичної влади в Нігері.
Однак російський вплив в усьому регіоні стає все більшим.
На Африку, надто на Західну Африку, спрямована досить потужна
проросійська пропаганда. Будь-який військовий переворот чи протистояння
із Заходом одразу набувають характер протистояння між Росією та Заходом.
Тому Росія сприймається, як природній союзник.
При тому, що люди, які махають прапорами,
Росію часто не можуть знайти на карті.
Тобто вони нічого про країну не знають, у них особливої прив'язаності до Росії немає.
Але Росія стає символом протистояння Заходу.
Нігер - сьомий найбільший виробник урану у світі.
А це - паливо для європейських атомних електростанцій.
Нині військова хунта припинила експорт урану в ЄС.
Експерти вважають, що Росія може спробувати замінити нігерський
уран своїм на світовому ринку.
Також Нігер вважався надійним союзником Заходу в Західній Африці
у боротьбі з джихадистами. Канцлер Німеччини Олаф
Шольц відвідував африканську державу торік і спостерігав, як солдати Бундесверу
допомагають навчати нігерських військових поблизу кордону з Малі.
Цей регіон є ключовим маршрутом для мігрантів, які прямують у Європу.
Також у Нігері досі залишаються французькі й американські військові.
Після перевороту їхню роль доведеться переглянути.
Наше військове співробітництво призупинене в будь-якому разі -
як на двосторонньому рівні, так і в рамках ЄС доти,
доки ситуація не проясниться. Наші військові досі розміщені там, на авіабазі.
На даний момент нам більше немає чого сказати.
Поки ситуація незрозуміла, і невідомо, чи продовжиться
тісна військова співпраця в майбутньому.
На противагу європейцям в Нігері можуть посилитися
джихадистські угруповання і ПВК "Вагнер".
Євген Пригожин уже привітав переворот в Нігері
й запропонував послуги своїх найманців у встановленні порядку в країні.
Це дає можливість "вагнерівцям" зайти в країну,
заробити грошей і зробити свої послуги знову затребуваними.
Адже після того, що сталося наприкінці червня в Росії,
діяльність ПВК "Вагнер" під великим питанням. Хто їх контролює,
якою є їхня роль у впливі на глобальну політику - усе це опинилося під питанням.
Якщо вони втрутяться в ситуацію в Нігері, це може надати їм ваги.
Російська ПВК "Вагнер" уже захищає президента
Центральноафриканської республіки, а бронзові "вагнерівці"
дивляться крізь приціли на вулиці столиці - Банґі.
А так в ЦАР проявляється духовний російський вплив.
Режис Саїн Клер Воємава - служитель церкви, яку спонсорує РПЦ.
Він перейшов з Константинопольського патріархату в серпні торік -
через п'ять місяців після повномасштабного вторгнення РФ в Україну.
Росіяни виправляють помилки, яких допустилися інші, наприклад,
Франція, яка завжди приносила нам війну.
Росія ніколи не колонізувала африканські країни.
Варто сказати, що Росія чудовий партнер в плані безпеки, надто для нашої країни,
яка розташована в самому серці Африки.
Нам постійно погрожують повстанці, терористи.
Ми щасливі, що наша держава - партнер Росії.
Не лише священики, а й блогери просувають в Африці російські наративи.
Уряд США і проєкт "Уся увага на "Вагнера" дійшли висновку,
що Москва платить низці впливових осіб за розповсюдження
пропаганди на африканському континенті.
Їх наймають, аби виявити найбільш гострі і суперечливі проблеми,
а потім - розпалювати почуття людей з цих тем.
А ось такі мультфільми поширюються в Малі, Буркіна-Фасо і Кот-Д'Івуарі.
Ми демони Макрона, тепер це наша країна.
Пропагандистський ролик у соцмережах побачили тисячі людей.
Експерти пов'язують його творців з ПВК "Вагнер".
Відео підігріває й так палкі антифранцузькі настрої
в колишніх французьких колоніях.
Експерти кажуть: на тлі своєї міжнародної ізоляції,
Росія прагне показати себе впливовим партнером і гарантом безпеки для Африки.
Росія є лідером за поставками зброї в африканські країни.
Частину озброєнь Москва передає безкоштовно.
Утім як довго це триватиме з огляду на війну в Україні - питання.
На даний момент російська економіка може це витримати -
забезпечити виконання цих обіцянок у короткостроковій перспективі.
Але ніхто не знає, як буде розвиватися ситуація далі.
Враховуючи, що на останній саміт "Росія-Африка" приїхало
менше лідерів, ніж на попередній, у країнах Африки є невпевненість
щодо майбутнього Росії й перспектив співробітництва з нею.
Після військового перевороту в Нігері експерти
побоюються ескалації насилля і в цій державі,
і в усьому й без того неспокійному регіоні.
Посилення антиєвропейських настроїв може змусити
європейські держави залишити Нігер.
Це призведе до зменшення їхнього впливу на роки,
а також може посилити активність терористичних
угруповань і спричинити нову хвилю біженців.